[Música]
ya lo estábamos tratando y es que en
Perú continúa la toma de Lima con miles
de manifestantes que llegaron desde
otras zonas del país 18 regiones se
vieron afectadas este jueves y las
autoridades tuvieron que cerrar el
aeropuerto de cusco de forma preventiva
y el de Arequipa ante lo que llamaron un
intento de toma en esa ciudad se
registró una nueva muerte elevando el
total de fallecidos a 55 mientras que
los ciudadanos marchan hacia limado
dentro de la capital la presidenta Dina
boluarte se reunió con una misión de la
ONU que pidió garantizar el derecho a la
protesta y promover el diálogo
conectamos con Francisco Zacarías
corresponsal de France 24 en Perú
Francisco cómo se ha desarrollado esta
jornada en el país
Buenas noches mientras la más importante
vías que unen al Perú se encuentran
bloqueadas en diferentes regiones este
país se acató un paro nacional Los
manifestantes se han desplegado en
diversos lugares de esta nación para
hacer oír su voz de protesta y rechazo a
la presidenta Dina boluarte Lima la
ciudad capital ha concentrado la mayor
atención porque miles de peruanos de
diferentes puntos de este país llegaron
a la capital peruana para realizar la
denominada toma de Lima el gobierno de
Dina boluarte despegó más de 1.500
oficiales de la policía para contener a
la manifestación a esta hora se registra
un incendio en los alrededores de la
plaza San Martín se trata de un edificio
donde se menciona que sería un estudio
de abogados que pertenecería al Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola estas
concentraciones se vienen desplegando
también en otros lugares de la capital
como los barrios acomodados de
Miraflores y San Isidro donde también se
viene produciendo enfrentamientos entre
los manifestantes y la policía ahí
ahorita una situación de tensión en la
ciudad capital y también se están
mencionando otro tipo de actividades a
través de las redes sociales que podrían
producirse entre los siguientes días
Francisco la presidentado el Duarte
llamó a los manifestantes a dialogar
Pero esto tras la represión en las
protestas algo que los ciudadanos exigen
no quede en la impunidad Cuál es el
panorama actual para la mandataria
bueno actualmente Dina boluarte tiene un
79% de desaprobación de los peruanos
según encuesta local Y estos días Frank
24 ha estado realizando un recorrido por
todo el sur del Perú siguiendo a los
manifestantes en muchos lugares que
hemos visitado ellos no quieren a la
mandataria al igual que en otras
regiones del Perú tal es el descontento
de los peruanos casta en la región de
chalgua Huacho que es el sitio natal de
Dina boluarte la población salió hoy a
protestar por las calles para exigir su
renuncia a esta horas Mejor dicho dentro
de las nueve de la noche hora Lima
Bogotá se espera un mensaje a los
peruanos de Dina boluarte mucho se habla
de que la mandataria estaría presentando
su dimisión o quizás anunciando nuevas
medidas para contener las protestas
estaremos atentos al desarrollo de esta
información